[Music]
on this Saturday night wild winter
weather from blizzards to thunder snow
Southern Ontario is slammed by a strange
storm it was just cool to be honest I
don't know like yeah it's I don't think
I've seen it before we'll tell you where
the weather system is heading next
screen time and suicide what new
research reveals about the risks for
children every hour that they spent on
screens actually was associated with a
slightly higher risk of future suicidal
behaviors from quiet quitting to quiet
promotion a new troubling workplace
Trend plus a world record-breaking
birthday for these two tiny Canadians
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us much of Southern Ontario is digging
out after a wild winter storm the
biggest snowfall of the season in the
greater Toronto area dropped as much as
30 centimeters of snow in some spots
grounding flights knocking out power for
thousands of homes and even unleashing a
rare phenomenon known as thundersnow as
Toria Israeli reports that storm system
is now working its Way East
the sky lit up and so did social media
with a relatively unusual sight
that crackling sound rang out across the
greater Toronto area
with lightning even striking the CN
tower we thought it was a Transformer
that was going and didn't think that it
was Thunder it was pretty impressive I
think I was happy to be inside though
outside this Toronto police officer was
in the middle of an interview people
that can't move anywhere because of the
types of tires or vehicles that they're
driving so
the wet snow and strong winds created
dangerous driving conditions hundreds of
flights were grounded Friday night and
into Saturday morning
the storm has led up but Crews expect
the cleanup will last days the city of
Toronto has deployed more than 1100
pieces of snow removal equipment as you
all saw the snow came down at extremely
fast rate and after that extremely fast
downfall clearing driveways is slow
going certainly it was a very heavy wet
snow and that's significant a lot of
moisture was in this snow so that was
significant because it meant a little
bit more difficult to to push it and
plow it and shovel it it was like
shoveling concrete it was so heavy the
sloppy mess is part of the same system
that brought snow to California it's
also hitting the national capital and
Quebec it might look like your typical
Ontario winter but it hasn't felt like
it despite all the snow it's been too
warm to skate on the Rideau Canal and
for the first time in history it's
staying closed all season it's been a
challenge to like see it and walk by it
every day and not be able to enjoy it
getting around after a month's worth of
snow fell in a single day it's been a
very uh different winter to say the
least but I really miss the canal not
being open and I'm hoping it'll all go
away soon enough a different kind of
winter many Canadians are ready to part
ways with
tariya isri Global News Ottawa
and let's bring in Global News senior
meteorologist Christy Gordon now for
more on that weather picture and what
comes next so Christy lots of snow even
thunder snow what can you tell us about
that
thanks so much Jeff yet so an exciting
evening that's for sure all across
Southern Ontario Thunder snowy is a rare
event but we do get it about once per
season tends to happen earlier in the
season or towards the beginning of
winter and then towards the end as well
so there were dozens of lightning
strikes across the region this is a shop
from the Toronto area and it was all
because of this low pressure center
which tracked across Southern Ontario
and created that instability and thus
the lightning it's the same type of
scenario that we would get in the
summertime although there are some
differences for example thunderstorms in
the wintertime tend to not be quite as
tall as they are in the summer as well
we get a little bit more Cloud to Cloud
lightning there was some Cloud to ground
lightning last night but overall the
Thunder itself is not quite as sharp the
snowfall which there was a lot of it
last night tends to muffle that sound a
little bit as we as also saw that strong
wind wind gusts easterly winds look at
Toronto at 76 kilometers an hour so it
was lightning snow blowing snow and
heavy snowfall across the area anywhere
from 15 to 32 centimeters in a 24-hour
period you can see Scarborough there
getting the most at that 32 so
substantial snowfall indeed it will take
quite a while for the crews to be able
to clear everything out now we do still
have a few more hours of snowfall
expected in the Montreal region but
overall this is going to shift out as we
continue through the evening hours one
thing I wanted to point out though we
still do have a few flurries possible
for southern Ontario overnight and it's
just a strong Northerly or northwesterly
flow that's going to kick up those
flurries but otherwise we are expecting
some sunshine tomorrow which will be
nice and in terms of snowfall
accumulation it will be minimal we're
talking about zero to three centimeters
I think the biggest issue over the next
little while will be that we'll see some
melt during the day with that Sunshine
milder conditions and then freezing at
night so that could cause some problems
Jeff back to you all right thanks
Christy
and winter storms are also wreaking
havoc South of the Border producing
tornadoes and heavy rains that left at
least seven people dead
Kentucky's Governor says at least two
tornadoes touched down as a storm system
ripped through the western part of that
state Winds of nearly 130 kilometers an
hour were reported enough to blow
tractor trailers right off the road the
storm is now moving to the Northeast
bringing heavy snow and sleet from
Michigan to New York state where more
than 30 centimeters of snow has already
fallen
and turning to Ukraine now Canada's
defense Chief just wrapped up his first
trip to that country since Russia's
full-scale Invasion General Wayne Iyer
met with Ukrainian military officials
and discussed bilateral defense
cooperation his visit comes as Russia
appears on the cusp of its first major
victory in months regichini reports
under constant Russian attack there are
fewer and fewer safe passageways into
and out of bakmut a city in Ukraine's
Eastern Donetsk region where fewer than
5 000 people remain we wanted to stay
but how can we this residence is it's
time for us to go while Ukraine has
stabilized the front line how long it
can hold it in place is unknown it's on
fire this Soldier says but Ukraine will
live
buckmut has been a target for months
weakened it's now almost entirely
encircled according to the leader of
Russia's mercenary Wagner group Moscow
sees this is a doorway to The donbass
Experts argue the town is small and
simply an obsession for Russia's
president and while securing it has come
at a steep price Victory could too it
will be a tactical victory for Putin but
it will be a strategic defeat because
he's
chewed up so many units trying to take
back moot Russia's confidence is getting
a slight boost it's defense minister
even making a rare trip into what it
calls russian-controlled Ukraine
awarding medals to his soldiers
good luck success and come home alive he
told them before meeting with military
leaders where more weapons and training
were discussed
the trip comes just one day after the
U.S announced another 400 million
dollars in crucial Aid these
contributions are making a significant
difference enabling Ukraine to defend
its sovereignty for Ukraine its future
remains on the line but for Russia it
comes down to the future of one man he's
a dictator who has cast the dice in a
failing military effort and he feels
it's necessary to have what he can be
sold as a victory in order to prevent
some kind of a social explosion at home
and while Ukraine says it won't withdraw
from bakmut It's Quickly running out of
time and resources Reggie Chaney Global
News Washington
Ukraine's first lady says prosecutors
are now investigating 171 cases of
sexual violence allegedly committed by
Russian troops olena zelenska says those
are only the official numbers adding
quote we don't know how many suffer in
silence she vowed those responsible will
not go unpunished zelenska was taking
part in a panel discussion on sexual
violence and war crimes today along with
the president of the European Parliament
I'm the mother of four Sons I would like
to be able to tell them
when Ukraine wins the war
that everybody will be held accountable
for the crimes that they have committed
and the atrocities that we have seen
committed against the brave ukrainians
well many of the sexual abuse victims
are women zelenska says 39 are men and
13 are minors
for days now the liberal government has
faced calls and political pressure to
hold a full public inquiry into
allegations Beijing try to interfere in
Canadian elections well so far prime
minister Justin Trudeau has resisted
saying parliamentary committees are
already investigating but that line has
done little to quell the calls including
from some experts who say the government
should start planning new legislation
now our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson has more on that Mercedes
Jeff there are lots of allegations and
questions around the foreign
interference file but not a lot of
transparency or Clarity this week on the
west block we go looking for answers
with some people in the know two top
former civil servants who were in their
positions under the Trudeau government
we'll sit down with Arthur wilczinski a
former senior public servant at a
Canadian intelligence agency and Michael
wernick the country's former top
bureaucrat who was Clerk of the privy
Council in 2019 ahead of the election
that took place later that year Warnick
says foreign interference is a serious
threat that the government needs to act
on to reassure Canadians well I think
one of the driving issues here is
retaining the confidence of Canadians
Trust of Canadians in not just elections
but their political institutions their
democracy and politicians so the issue
is much broader than where it started a
few weeks ago about China's role in a
specific election I think we do now have
an issue about
retaining Canadians trust in in their
Democratic process over the last week
MP's grilled senior National Security
officials on the details of the China
interference file at a parliamentary
committee looking into the issue the
committee ultimately recommended a
public inquiry take place something the
prime minister is resisting so far
wernick says the government doesn't need
to wait for a public inquiry though to
do something now we don't have to wait a
year and a half for its findings I can
tell you the findings already it will
recommend that we take the Australian
and UK models of foreign interference
legislation and registration and bring
them to Canada so there's nothing
stopping our politicians from working on
that legislation in parallel the
government could commit to table a bill
like that before the summer break and
and our politicians could debate it
amend it make it better and pass it by
the end of the year Arthur wilczinsky
who was the associate Deputy minister at
Canada's signals in intelligence agency
says foreign interference is a top
priority for intelligence agencies in
Canada and that more can be done to
level with Canadians about what has been
going on so I think as transparency is
essential and I think transparency is
something that we can do more of within
the security intelligence Community
we'll have more on that story plus a
look at how all of this my might shake
out as MPS return to Parliament that's
what's ahead on the show this week Jeff
thanks Mercedes And as she mentioned you
can watch that full interview tomorrow
on the west block
the link between excessive screen time
and suicide coming up with new research
reveals about the risks for children who
spend hours staring at screens plus how
these torontonian twins landed a spot in
the Guinness world record books
trying to moderate the time that
children spend staring at their screens
is a familiar challenge for families but
now research from the U.S is adding new
urgency to that discussion the study
found a link between excessive screen
time and suicidal behaviors in pre-teens
researchers say it can lead to social
isolation cyber bullying and sleep
disruption but as Catherine Ward
explains there are some simple steps
families can take to mitigate the risks
television tablets and texting screens
are everywhere greens are here to stay
and to some extent people need to use
them for communication school work and
increasingly daily work however a recent
study raised some red flags when it
comes to how excessive screen time could
influence children 9 to 11 years old
every hour that they spent on screens
actually was associated with the
slightly higher risk of future suicidal
behaviors the study looked at more than
11 000 kids in the U.S participants
reported an average of four hours of
Total screen time per day day each
additional hour of total screen time was
then associated with a nine percent
increased risk of suicidal behaviors
when followed up two years later
while these numbers might sound alarming
at face value experts caution not to
jump to any conclusions I think the jury
is still out as to whether or not screen
time causes suicide and mental health or
potentially kids who already are
depressed are just using screens more
with others saying there can be benefits
to screen time they mentioned
multiplayer games as potentially being a
source of bullying but could also be a
source of social interaction and uplift
and connection and an important benefit
so it really isn't about the screens
it's about what's happening on the
screens and what are you doing with them
regardless when it comes to healthy
screen time caregivers have a leading
role to play for modeling good habits
avoiding screen time particularly before
bedtime or having screen free times
during family meals so that you can
focus on eating and creating connection
wherever possible one of the really
interesting things that's come up in
this research year after year is that
kids don't report wanting to spend all
of their time playing on their iPads or
watching TV or YouTube videos they talk
about wanting to spend more time with
family with grandparents Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
still ahead quiet promotion why the
latest workplace Trend isn't all it's
cracked up to be
welcome back you've probably heard of
quiet quitting the term for employees
who put minimum effort into their jobs
well there's a new workplace trend for
2023 called quiet promotion and as Ann
gaviola explains it may not be as
beneficial as it sounds being quiet
promoted is when you get more
responsibilities you take on more work
you get to do more things while keeping
the same job title and keeping the same
pay acquired promotions don't come with
a pay bump or a title increase just more
work besides you get paid in experience
am I right a promotion sounds good but
beware the quiet promotion that is
exploitation career strategists sweat to
regmy has experienced it herself I've
been there seen that as well and when I
reflect back I felt like you know what
that was a wage theft and labor abuse
quiet promotion also known as quiet
hiring has become more common in this
labor market where job vacancies abound
it could be weeks or even months before
you fill a position the other reason for
it though is coming out of the pandemic
a lot of companies are are not flush
financially so they can't afford to hire
a new person it could lead to career
advancement it can be very positive for
an employee that is getting the
opportunity to learn new skills to learn
new ways of doing things but it can also
lead to more vacancies if the employers
are not going to the root cause of
what's causing them to back feel it all
the time what's causing them to
cross-train people all the time theirs
can be burnt out people are going to
quit U.S Consulting and research firm
Gartner identified quiet hiring was one
of the top workplace trends of 2023. it
comes on the heels of 2022's quiet
quitting which refers to doing your job
but nothing Beyond what's required quiet
quitting has given rise to bare minimum
Monday which as the name suggests is a
form of presenteeism or rather
resenteeism some suggest quiet
promotions should be treated like
internal hires I would like to see the
compensations and the job descriptions
and the contracts and that would be the
right way of hiring internally and
compensating them with a fair package in
other words promoting loudly and gaviola
Global News Toronto
up next indigenous culture and coding
how a Saskatchewan school is teaching
Tech to First Nations and metis students
[Music]
welcome back a pair of Ontario twins are
celebrating their first birthday by
Landing a spot in the Guinness record
books as the world's most premature
twins Adia and Adriel nadaraja were born
on this day last year after just a
22-week pregnancy their parents say
doctors gave the babies around a zero
percent chance of survival when their
mother went into labor She was
transferred to the neonatal Intensive
Care Unit at Toronto's Mount Sinai
Hospital which offers care for infants
born after 22 weeks
I was experiencing a lot of bleeding and
I didn't know if I could hold the babies
in until they got to the 22 weekend zero
Mark but I knew that I had to hold the
babies in because if I didn't they
wouldn't be alive
now one year later and after nearly six
months in intensive care the tiny twins
are marking their first birthday with
not one but two World Records they're
also the lightest twins at Birth at a
combined weight of just 750 grams
happy birthday now Saskatchewan High
School is preserving indigenous culture
and history by looking to the Future
students are receiving lessons in
computer science and coding and then
learning how to use those skills to
remix indigenous music cabbie Mali
Theron reports
it wasn't just binaries and algorithms
at this coding event sounded Rhythm were
just as important students from
Bethlehem Catholic High School and St
Joseph High School got to remix
indigenous music through coding it's
really interesting how they put coding
and music together since I'm a band
student
um
music has also always been my passion
it's part of your Voice's power a
program that teaches computer science
while learning about indigenous history
in Canada they want to encourage more
students from diverse and
underrepresented backgrounds to explore
the tech world this educator is on board
definitely with the direction that our
industry is going it's important the
students get more get moved with
computers and how to code programs and
use all those different skills in the
real world
oh foreign
according to a 2020 conference Board of
Canada report fewer than 2 percent of
people working in stem are indigenous
creating a need for a computer science
program with indigenous education
Friday's lesson plan included Saskatoon
born indigenous hip-hop artist Dakota
bear speaking to the crowd on his
journey to pursue his dreams while
staying true to his culture that message
hitting home with Alex trong we're all
just human beings like it doesn't even
matter where you're from whether you're
indigenous Asian anything we just we all
need to support each other while some
students aren't sure if this is their
destined career choice
um maybe you know it's all like kind of
complicated you know I'm still feeling
young trying to figure things out it's
an experience that this teacher believes
these students will look back on anytime
that they get a day like this where they
get to go away and have a different
experience it always imprints on them
and gives them memories that they
remember for years copy
Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is a very snowy Wycliffe
British Columbia we love seeing your
Canada so please keep emailing your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching pharah Nasser will
be back here at the anchor desk with you
tomorrow have a great night
foreign